Hello and welcome, everyone, to our Network Security class.
My name is Dan Boneh and I'm a professor of computer science, here, at Stanford University.
and I'm really excited and looking forward to telling you everything about Network Security.
So, in this course, we're going to learn a number of topics in network security
We're going to focus about, first of all, how the internet works
how internet protocols operate
and then we're going to look at various security problems with these internet protocols
You're going to learn how to deploy network defense tools
and basically how to manage a network so that it's harder to compromise
Then we're going to switch gears and talk about a specific type of attack called a denial of service attack,
and there are many, many types of attacks that come under the guise of denial of service
We're going to tell you how those attacks work and teach you how to defend against those attacks.
And, finally, we'll talk about the DoS protocol which is probably the most widely used security protocol on the Internet.